patience is the most beautiful prayer
there is no hand to catch time
to give jewels to a donkey is as stupid
as giving a eunuch to a woman
the thief that is not caught is a king
who does not climb will not fall either
when an elephant is in trouble even a
frog will kick him
[Music]
it is hard for an ex-king to become a
night watchman
where the needle goes the thread follows
don't eat your bread on someone else's
table
the first day a guest the second day a
guest the third day a calamity
when you drink milk under a palm tree
people will say that it is palm wine
he that is bald-headed has no need for a
comb
don't poison someone whom you can kill
with sweets
[Music]
pull someone by the ears and his head
will follow
stolen sugar is the sweetest
among the blind the one-eyed man is king
you must answer the devil in his own
language
[Music]
if you live on the river befriend the
crocodile
[Music]
the voice of the poor has no echo
the world flatters the elephant and
tramples on the ant
the word of a woman is a bundle of water
use medicine as well as prayers
three foolish things to sing to the deaf
to talk with the dumb and to dance for
the blind
you should not call in a cat to settle
an argument between two birds
after three days both fish and guests
smell
he who works as a slave eats as a king
in love beggar and king are equal
[Music]
if you can't give any sugar then speak
sweetly
he who has a true friend has no need of
a mirror
the body dies the fame lives on
[Music]
the potter sleeps soundly for no one
would steal clay
god laughs when you steal from a thief
you may lock up the [ __ ] but the sun
will still rise
pearls are of no value in a desert
a tree starts with a seed
everyone looking downward becomes
impressed with ideas of his own
greatness
but looking upwards he feels his own
smallness
[Music]
a thief thinks everybody steals
freedom is not worth having if it does
not include the freedom to make mistakes
poverty makes thieves like love makes
poets
greatness is not the fruit of birth but
of effort
one of the two partners always bites the
best part of an apple
after eating 900 rats the cat is now
going on a pilgrimage
the way to overcome the angry man is
with gentleness the evil man with
goodness
the miser with generosity and the liar
with truth
without men in the neighborhood all the
women are chaste
when the devil leaves heaven enters
to long for everything sorrow
to accept everything joy
always be well dressed even when begging
the enemy's own punishment is his envy
[Music]
great minds discuss ideas
average minds discuss events
little minds disgust people
love from someone who is bad is worse
than his hatred
it is better to be blind than to see
things from only one point of view
[Music]
don't let grass grow on the path of
friendship
[Music]
there are only two things from which to
choose profit or loss
a buffalo does not feel the weight of
his own horns
[Music]
it is easy to forget a kindness
but one remembers cruelty
the eyes do not see what the mind does
not want
a person consists of his faith whatever
is his faith even so is he
be careful of deep water and dogs that
do not bark
[Music]
a book is like a garden carried in the
pocket
you have to believe in gods to see them
money is the best servant
have faith god calls forth life even
from eggs
it is worse to excuse than to offend
[Music]
what was hard to bear is sweet to
remember
where there is a glut of words there is
a dearth of intelligence
follow the river and you will get to the
sea
we admire what we do not understand
[Music]
it is better to sit down than to stand
better to lie down than to sit
but death is best of all
in a deserted village the jackass is
king
health is wealth
you can often find in rivers what you
cannot find in oceans
no strength within
no respect without
a problem is solved when it gets tougher
speak like a parrot
meditate like a swan
chew like a goat and bathe like an
elephant
where the sun shines there is also shade
a known mistake is better than an
unknown truth
there are many people who can sing but
don't know the words
it is easy to throw something into the
river but hard to get it out again
you cannot separate water by beating it
with a fork
in a tree that you cannot climb there
are always a thousand fruits
any water in the desert will do
dependence on another is perpetual
disappointment
though the snake be small
it is still wise to hit it with a big
stick
to loan is to buy troubles
[Music]
blaming your faults on your nature does
not change the nature of your faults
the poor man looks for food the rich man
looks for appetite
[Music]
the person who misses a chance and the
monkey who misses its branch can't be
saved
hunger drives good taste away
smiles that you broadcast will always
come back to you
where love reigns the impossible may be
attained
[Music]
many families are built on laughter
better to have a diamond with a few
small flaws than a rock that is perfect
something done at the wrong time should
be regarded as not done
if you throw a handful of stones at
least one will hit the target
a thief is a thief whether he steals a
diamond or a cucumber
they who give have all things they who
withhold have nothing
the most beautiful things in the
universe are the starry heavens above us
and the feeling of duty within us
when money is not a servant it is a
master
poverty destroys all virtues
without love everything is in vain
[Music]
truth has no branches
[Music]
not all the buds on a bush will blossom
[Music]
drops join to make a stream
ears combined to make a crop
if a man from humble beginnings gets
rich he will carry his umbrella at
midnight
all the water in the sea doesn't reach
the knees of the man who fears not death
for the first five years of your son's
life treat him as a prince
for the next 10 years as a slave
for the rest of his life as a friend
non-violence is the supreme law of life
don't bargain for fish that are still in
the water
[Music]
do what the moolah says but don't do
what he does
the heart at rest sees a feast in
everything
learning is a treasure no thief can
touch
[Music]
he who answers is inferior to he who
asks
the worst kind of poverty is to have
many debts
we can't change the direction of the
wind but we can adjust the sails
[Music]
to the world wisdom is folly to the wise
the world is folly
a house without a woman is the devil's
own lodging
every dog is a tiger in his own street
it is better to pick a fight with your
in-laws than with your neighbors
large desire is endless poverty
greed is the root cause of sorrow
[Music]
the reputation lost on trivial things
cannot be regained by donating alms
no one was ever lost on a straight road
you may look up for inspiration
or look down in desperation
but do not look sideways for information
the pain is sometimes preferable to the
treatment
when the bed breaks there is the ground
to lie on
[Music]
good people like clouds receive only to
give away
when we take one step toward god
he takes seven steps toward us
complaining is the weak man's weapon
when anger comes wisdom goes
a spoiled son becomes a gambler
while a spoiled daughter becomes a
harlot
one man's beard is burning and another
warms his hands by it
for the friendship of two the patience
of one is required
be like a camel carrying sweets but
dining on thorns
agriculture is best enterprise is
acceptable
but avoid being on a fixed wage
it is little used to dig a well after
the house has caught fire
better a hundred enemies outside the
house than one inside
life is like the flame of a lamp
it needs a little oil now and then
drop by drop a pitcher is filled
deceive me about the price but not about
the goods
[Music]
he who wants fruit should not pick
flowers
happy is the woman whose husband does
not speak to her
an ounce of practice is worth a thousand
words
you